you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's program
as another energy supplier collapses sky
news analysis finds households could
soon be spending the biggest ever share
of their income on fuel could this put
the uk's climate targets under threat
planetary emergency campaigners call for
a u.n treaty to tackle rising plastic
pollution
and drivers in london could soon be
paying more as the mayor acts to cut
emissions and meet the capital's net
zero targets
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now the phasing out of inefficient
fossil fuel subsidies was a key
commitment of world leaders at the cop
climate summit back in november
but is the global energy crisis putting
that commitment under threat
soaring gas prices and a renewable
energy supply unable to yet fill the gap
have fueled a rise in the cost of living
in the uk
and this week there's a warning that the
proportion of households struggling with
energy bills is set to triple in the
spring when the price cap is expected to
rise
so let's take a look then at how the
country's power mix is looking right now
and as you can see fossil fuels are
powering over half of our electricity
generation including around two percent
coming from coal well our economics and
data editor has taken a deep dive into
the energy crisis his series of reports
includes a look at the uk's energy mix
and how the aim of shifting to
renewables is affecting it but first
here's his analysis of how consumers are
being affected
here in britain and in much of the world
people are trying to work out how to
keep their heads above financial water
in the coming months
getting to the stage now where
do i pay for food or do i pay for heat
we sort of watch our smart meter
thinking
is it going to be a really painful month
this month i'm going to be afraid to
switch the lights on
because the power bill is going to be
ridiculous
how much of an impact will higher energy
bills have to find out we need to drill
down into what we spend our money on
this bong represents the weekly spending
of an average household 588 pounds in
total and let's just break it down so of
that you've got about 53 pounds being
spent a week on restaurants on hotels
you've got 75 pounds on recreation and
culture 82 pounds on transport uh on
food and drink you've got 64 pounds you
see here how this starts to add up and
then you've got things you can't avoid
things like mortgage and council tax 50
pounds income tax and national insurance
that's the biggest slice 146 pounds but
on top of all of this there it is
electricity and gas 25 pounds now that
may not sound like much but bear in mind
that's based on bills back in 2020 if
the energy price cap goes up to 2 000
pounds this spring and that's what the
formula suggests look at the red slice
it's up to 38 pounds a week if the price
cap rises again later this year to 2400
pounds again it looks plausible look at
that slice up to 46 pounds now to put
that into context let's just look back
at this over time so you're looking at
the proportion that that slice had as a
percentage of the total going back to
the 1970s you can see very high in the
70s coming down to low levels in the 90s
and the 2000s but just look at what
happens if you have that price cap up to
2000. you're talking about 5.6
of total spending that's the highest
that we've seen since the late 80s and
if it's up to 2400 pounds again look at
that line up to 6.8
of total spending the highest on record
higher than we saw in the 1970s during
that famous crisis and bear in mind the
impact is greater for certain households
so back to those bars that we saw a
second ago look you can see the average
there you can see the highest 10 so more
spending on top the lowest 10 as well
and we'll just add on those shares that
are going down uh to energy after those
two price caps and you can see that for
the average household seven percent we
saw that a moment ago just under seven
percent for the top 10
4 so a smaller fraction of the total but
just look at the lowest 10
13
of total spending that is a massive
squeeze
there are about 2 million households in
england that are in fuel stress who pay
more than 10 of their household incomes
on energy bills which is a general sign
of energy being unaffordable and what we
found was that as soon as when prices
jump by more than 50 overnight this
number will triple to more than 6
million
when you add it up we're talking about
the kind of hit to real incomes you
don't tend to see outside of a serious
recession which is why this is likely to
be one of the defining issues of the
year
now together energy has become the
latest casualty of the energy crisis the
supplier which was part owned by
warrington council and had 176 000
households on its books has collapsed as
gas prices continue to soar more than
two dozen firms have failed since august
last year when the wholesale gas price
crisis took hold
now rising plastic pollution is creating
a planetary emergency a report is
warning the research by the
environmental investigation agency
argues that the only way to tackle one
of the biggest threats to the
environment is for united nations member
states to agree a treaty which sets
targets to reduce plastic production and
waste well the study finds that plastic
emissions in the oceans alone are due to
triple by 2040 in line with plastics
production by 2040 there'll be 646
million tons of plastics in the world
seas which could exceed the collective
weight of all fish in the ocean
and around 92 percent of all plastic at
the ocean's surface is microplastic
fragments barely visible to the naked
eye that have either broken down from
larger debris or were made that way
we're at a really critical point now
where we can take all of the learnings
from the last you know from the
conventions in the 90s and the rio
summit conventions and everything that's
common since then so take all that
learning
and apply in the context of
plastics but i mean fundamentally
we um
in order to see a measurable tangible
improvement we need to change the our
relationship with plastics as materials
which means reducing how much new
plastic we create you know being mindful
of what we do produce making sure that
we design products that are durable and
reusable and treating them as the
valuable the valuable resources that
they are it's such a trans boundary
problem and because plastic is
completely ubiquitous and literally
everywhere all over the world
um in our daily lives
both in products but also as pollution
we need we need our global our global
global leaders to act on our behalf
and this is where the global treaty
comes in it can be seen as that giant
key that unlocks that door to sort of
really addressing this issue in all of
its forms
now some of the days other climate news
and the government has suffered a
setback in its attempt to give police
more powers to curb disruptive protests
the house of lords rejected some of the
more contentious provisions of the
police crime sentencing and courts bill
which targets environmentalists who've
blocked roads and glued themselves to
commuter trains to protest about climate
change
the uk high court threw out a case
brought by climate activists against oil
and gas regulator oga rejecting the
argument that the oga unlawfully
subsidized the fossil fuel sector it's a
setback for activists who are
increasingly using the courts to force a
reduction in oil and gas production
ash coating the main island of tonga
following a volcanic explosion over the
weekend is contaminating rainwater that
people rely on to drink
new zealand's military is sending fresh
water and other humanitarian supplies
but ash covering the runway will delay
the flight's arrival by another day
now motorists driving in london are
facing further charges in plans to
reduce carbon emissions and improve air
quality london mayor sadiq khan is
considering a number of different
options which would reduce traffic by at
least 27 in the capital by the end of
the decade in order to meet climate
change targets he says that a new kind
of road user charging system will need
to be implemented by 2030 at the latest
so one potential plan which will replace
any current vehicle charges is a fair
road user charging scheme now this means
that drivers will pay per mile with
different rates depending on how
polluting their vehicles are the level
of congestion in the area as well as
access to public transport
another proposal which could be
implemented more quickly is to extend
the ultra low emission zone now it will
cover the whole of greater london using
the current charge level and emission
standards
a daily low-level clean air charge is
also being considered for all except the
cleanest vehicles and this could be
introduced on its own or alongside an
extended ultra-low emission zone
and another possible approach is a
greater london boundary change now
charge rather this means all non-london
registered vehicles entering greater
london would be charged a small fee
there are three big challenges facing
our city going forward in relation to
the environment uh there's uh tackling
climate emergency
we know we've got to reduce uh
greenhouse gas emissions to zero there's
the air pollution we've got to reduce
air pollution because it's leading to
thousands of premature deaths children
with stunted lungs adults with a whole
host of health issues from asthma to
cancer dementia to heart disease but
also we've got to cut congestion because
too many londoners spend too much time
stuck in their cars stuck in traffic the
average londoner who drives spends
almost six days stacking their car 150
hours costs our economy five billion
pounds what i've published today is an
independent report how we get to net
zero by 20 for a wake-up call to the
government to give us more support to
tackle these triple challenges but also
i want to take londoners with us it's a
conversation i'm starting with londoners
about how we reduce road traffic over
the course of the next eight years one
of the things i'm quite clear about is
the poorest londoners least likely to
own a car who suffer the worst
consequences from air pollution
congestion and the climate emergency i'm
going to try and encourage londoners
working together how we can have over
the course of the next eight or nine
years about a quarter 27 fewer journeys
in their cars a number of things we've
got to do
make it safer for people to cycle
encourage people to walk and make public
transport an attractive alternative
coming up here on the daily climate show
we'll be talking a bit more about
congestion charging in cities in just a
moment with the director of policy and
translation at the grantham institute
elissa gilbert and professor of global
change science at university college
london and the university of leeds simon
lewis
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
director of policy and translation at
the grantham institute alyssa gilbert a
professor of global change science at
university college london and university
of leeds simon lewis so welcome to both
of you nice to see you both
so a war on motorists or a good day for
london's kids sadiq khan's plans to
clean up london's air by charging people
for using their cars have received some
mixed reviews the london mayor says air
pollution and the climate emergency are
an issue of social justice across the
globe and the poorest and least likely
to own a car are suffering the
consequences so alyssa what do you think
charging people more to drive their cars
is that a good idea as far as the
planet's concerned
well i think it's it's not quite as
stark as you put it it's an extension of
what we call the polluter pays principle
really we want people to have to pay a
little bit more who are doing more
damage to our environment and in fact
people's health so i think what the
mayor is suggesting is a more complex
structure of paying to use roads than we
have at the moment in london we've got
the congestion charge and you pay if you
use public transport but it's a bit
blunt really so i think what we're
hearing is this idea of a more
sophisticated set of charging
instruments that really reflects the
amount of pollution that you might be
causing well yes and one of the ideas
isn't it simon is to get people to use
cleaner vehicles if they are going to
drive but the criticism is i think the
rac makes it is that cleaner vehicles
are just too expensive for most people
electric vehicles cost more to buy don't
they
they do a present but what we
really
should be doing is looking at the
alternatives making the clean green
choice
walking cycling electric bikes public
transport the sensible option and the
last option of those is is an electric
vehicle or a conventional vehicle and
that's where the focus on the pricing
goes too far because we really need to
focus on the infrastructure to make
cycling safe
on making public transport as accessible
as possible and then that can work for
londoners because those are often
cheaper choices than
using a car and then we'll be able to
drive people away from this mode of
transport that's contributing air
pollution and also death from road
traffic accidents to move away from that
and then we'll have more
freeroads free from congestion for the
actual professional drivers who need it
the paramedics that need to get to
emergencies the plumbers who need to get
to people's houses with their tools and
then we'll have a much greener more
livable city alyssa do you think that
would work and there are huge challenges
with that aren't they making public
transport cheaper is going to be very
expensive some people are scared of
cycling in cities because of all the
vehicles around and also people like the
individual freedom of thinking i want to
get in my car and go where i want to go
well i think we shouldn't overestimate
the amount of change that this is for
london london is a fantastic city in
terms of transport options we have all
kinds of buses tubes um trams we have
you can even travel on that sky car
across london at one point
um we've got a riverboat we're using all
modes of transport in london we've got
parts of london that are extremely
walkable with local services close by so
we're not thinking about transforming
something from one state car only to
something completely different it's
really just
a gentle
nudging almost to demonstrate to people
that they've got these other options in
front of them and to use them and it
won't be appropriate for everyone all
the time that's not what this is about
but i do think it's very possible
especially in a city like london well
yes and one of the things being
considered simon i think is this idea of
charging people who are outside of a
greater london zone to come into it
isn't that likely to hit those people
who can't afford to live in central
london people who are paid less like
carers teachers nhs staff potentially
and they're going to get penalised for
travelling in well i think these plans
have got to be very carefully uh
considered to make sure that they are
not impacting the poorest members of
society
but again we
encouraging want to encourage people
onto public transport from outer london
to get into central london and that's
making
those public transport services as
affordable as possible so they're more
attractive than than taking your car
and alyssa how do you get people on side
to plans like this
well i think
it's it's not by a sort of big scary
newspaper headline it's obviously by
engaging with people speaking to them
proper consultation and really listening
to their concerns and really hearing
them so there will be some people with
genuine concerns you just mentioned some
groups of people who will be concerned
about how they travel
how do they feel like they're traveling
safely how can they make the most of
other travel or transport opportunities
people perhaps with concerns about their
businesses but they'll also be people
there who will genuinely see the
opportunity for gain so i think it's
making an amount of time for proper
engagement and consultation with a wider
group of people in the city and that's a
really important part of planning the
policy and then i think also leaving
space to test the policy and then
allowing a little bit of tweaking to
make it work um work well and work
better
okay let's move on to our second topic
shall we because investment fund
managers aren't generally household
names but if you are gonna know one it
would probably be larry fink chief
executive of blackrock now in his latest
annual letter to ceos he said that
pushing climate policies was about
profits not being woke so what
difference can an intervention like this
actually make so simon larry fink says
that they focus on sustainability not
because they're environmentalists but
because they're capitalists so
do interventions like this make any real
difference to corporate behaviour do you
think
i think it is an important intervention
although
when the media portray things as woke
that's usually about not having a
conversation about something rather than
having a meaningful conversation about
it and what larry fink is saying is that
even from his very narrowest perspective
of just making more money
it makes sense to drive down emissions
as fast as possible to get to net zero
and push for the policies to do that
from that narrow perspective and that's
really important and it's important for
him as a leader in the investment
community and it's important for leaders
in all aspects of society to speak up
about the need to stabilize the climate
system and that's what's important here
and what larry fink is saying but where
i differ from him
is that i think this energy transition
we can go through this energy transition
not just by
being net zero consumers but by
allowing people to to have a better
lives rather than just enriching the
billionaire class that larry fink
is part of
well yes and alyssa there is a suspicion
when any big businessman speaks out
isn't there there's always a worry that
there's some green washing going on
somewhere among some companies and i
know that one
ben cushing from the sierra club
example has said there's not much to see
here other than more hot air from a
would-be climate leader do you think
that's a fair criticism
well i think really it's a message that
he's giving um to inspire other people
around him to act uh so
i i that seems a little bit unfair to me
it's of course part of a longer message
that he sent out to investors as a
leader in that community
where he talks about a lot of other
things as well as acting sustainably and
i think it's fantastic i think to see
the sustainability message in there and
what could otherwise be just a very
strong invest carefully invest wisely
think about the long-term
kind of message that he's sending to
those people who really trust him and
hear his voice um so
he doesn't need to see it at all
actually um so i think we should
recognize it as a really positive
message sent
within his community and simon do you
think that persuading big corporations
to make green choices is is more
important than governments making green
policies are are the two things
inextricably linked
it's what's important is
the government because they set the
regulatory framework they set the laws
within which these corporations operate
so get those laws right to drive down
emissions to near zero and the companies
will have to follow but of course
companies are incredibly important in
terms of their power and influence so in
some senses they are inextricably linked
but one thing
that governments have is that they their
populations can hold them to account
so that they can drive this zero project
forward to stabilize the climate system
and your line just about held up there
but alyssa a final thought from you
business leaders political leaders
celebrities which are the voices you
most welcome speaking out on this issue
what do you think makes the most
difference as far as the public is
concerned
the unexpected voices there are a lot of
people out there that
the the public are expecting to hear say
these things but when you hear it come
from left field a really different voice
that's really important because the
people who usually trust that person on
other issues are going to hear something
new for the first time and think about
it differently than if they hear it from
the usual suspects okay well alyssa
gilbert and simon lewis always
interesting to get your take on things
thanks very much indeed
and tomorrow i'm going to be joined by
the chief executive of climate group
helen clarkson and environmentalist and
columnist for the guardian george monbio
that's it for now thanks for watching
see you next time
[Music]